the European Union is shrouded in
uncertainty Russia the Middle East
terrorism immigration signs something
that suggests EU security should be
strengthened the european parliament has
put the european defence union back on
the table there is crisis around europe
in many places and unfortunately during
last year we also have seen lots of
terrorist attacks on our soil so it
means that the main aim is to join our
resources also in defence and security
of the european union european forces
already operate in the Horn of Africa
and in the western Indian Ocean and peas
proposed to establish a headquarters to
plan and command more crisis management
operations in a move that will see two
percent of GDP go to defense with
Trump's unexpected election some
concerns have been raised about
international security the
president-elect have been questioned on
several occasions America's position
within NATO while pointing out the
complementarity between NATO and the EU
mep s also sent a clear message it does
not forget the NATO is a collective
defense alliance and not a company whose
unprofitable branches could be shut down
born from the lessons of two world wars
and men to defend and promote the values
which brought us together in the you too
[Music]